-Welcome back, everybody.
We're talking with
Ewan McGregor,
who you can see in
the new "Star Wars" series
"Obi-Wan Kenobi."
In "Obi-Wan Kenobi," our pal,
Hayden Christensen,
returns for the first time
as Darth Vader.
-Yeah.
-What's it like
working with Hayden again?
-It's lovely to work with
Hayden again.
We spent such
a long time together.
We shot episode 2 and 3
in Australia,
in Sydney, Australia,
back in the day.
And so we spent
a lot of time on set
and we had
a lot of fight training to do
and we spent
a lot of time off set.
So, it was nice to
see him again.
-Yeah, he's a good guy.
-It was frightening to see
him again, though,
in the -- I hadn't acted with
Darth Vader, you know.
-Oh, yeah.
-So -- And I've
been acting a long time.
I think I've done
a lot of stuff.
But the first take
with Darth Vader
scared the [bleep] out of me.
It's true.
-'Cause he's just frightening.
-Yeah, we rehearsed, and he
didn't have the helmet on.
And I was --
Then I was getting made up,
and I guess they were
sorting him out.
And then they went, "Action!"
And I'm walking down
and I hear something.
I turn around,
to [bleep] Vader's coming at me.
I swear to God.
I just about [bleep]
my pants, really.
-Yeah. But, I mean,
when you're a kid,
that is probably one of
the scariest villains you see.
-That's it, I think.
-A lot of people say that.
-I was like 7 years old again.
It was really like a --
It was really genuine fear.
I've made
horror films and stuff.
They're not frightening.
But that was.
-That was, yeah.
The series is pretty much
shrouded in secrecy,
but that does not stop fans
from having ideas or speculating
what might happen or what they
hope might happen in the series.
I was thinking,
if it's okay with you,
can I ask you a couple things?
You don't have to say
"yes" or "no," but --
-Oh, okay.
-But you can answer
the best you can,
and we can try to figure out if
some of these things
are happening.
-Okay.
-Fans want to know if we'll see
Obi-Wan Kenobi interact with
a young Luke Skywalker?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
-[ Breathes deeply ]
-Wow! Wow! Wow!
Okay, just an exhale.
That one just got an exhale.
Okay, okay.
-Maybe. Maybe.
-Okay. I'll take the "maybe."
It did get an exhale,
which is pretty good.
The fans are gonna
look into that.
Fans are hoping to see
exploration of
the galaxy and other planets.
Wow. Okay, that was an exhale,
but then swallowed it back.
You swallowed it back.
-Yeah.
-It came out,
and then you go, "Nope."
-I didn't want to repeat -- I
didn't want to repeat myself.
-No, of course. Yeah.
Oh, fans want to know if
there's a new droid sidekick.
Wow! That got a shift.
That got a shift and a flip.
-There might be.
-That got a shift and a flip.
'Cause that's always fun,
if there's a new --
-Shift flips.
-No, yeah.
But, no, but if they --
The ship lapse.
-Oh.
-A -- Yeah, exactly.
Flip ships, yeah.
If there's are new --
a new droid,
a new little buddy to
hang out with,
that's kind of fun.
Okay.
Fans want to know if
we're going to see Obi-Wan
try to redeem Darth Vader.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-[ Exhales sharply ]
-Wow!
That one got a Steel --
Like Blue Steel looking at me.
You looked through
my soul there.
-Yeah.
-Because you guys -- You guys
are basically brothers.
You kind of started together,
and then he went to
the dark side.
And then -- You know.
Okay. Alright.
Uh -- Ooh! Then the last one.
Fans want to see a rematch
between Obi-Wan and Darth Vader.
[ Audience cheers ]
That one got a "Whoo!"
Okay.
Alright, that one got a smile.
I'm going to take that
as something.
What can we say?
Because I've seen every trailer
I think known to man
that I can see about this thing.
-Yeah.
-It's on Disney+.
They do such a great job,
by the way.
-It's so cool.
It really is a nice --
It really is.
It sits like 8, 10 years
after "Episode III,"
and there's lots of, like,
satisfying threads between
"Episode III:
Revenge of the Sith"
and "A New Hope"
with Alec Guinness.
And I think, you know,
we spent a long time finding
the right story to tell.
And Deborah Chow is such
a brilliant director,
and she directed all
the episodes.
And she tells it her way,
so it's really --
It's really got her mark on it.
And it's pretty --
I've seen them all,
and I think they're really good.
So I think people
will not be disappointed.
-There you go.
I'm going to take it
from you, bud.
We love you.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ewan McGregor in
"Obi-Wan Kenobi."
Take a look at this.
-There's more to life
than your farm, Owen.
He needs to see that.
There's a whole galaxy
out there.
-I'm asking you to
leave us alone, Ben.
I mean it.
-Is he okay?
-You don't care if he's okay.
You care if he's showing.
-He's my responsibility, Owen.
-Well, I'm his uncle.
-We talked about this.
When the time comes,
he must be trained.
-Like you trained his father?
-Whoa!
-Come on.
-Snap!
That's what I'm talking about!
Ewan McGregor, everybody.
"Obi-Wan Kenobi" premieres
this Friday on Disney+.